richard christie was telling me during
the break that he used to beat off to
what did you beat off to richard the
first time i ever had like an actual
orgasm
i didn't even touch myself i was looking
at a bass pro shops catalog
they were advertising
a uh an inner tube and it was just a
woman holding an inner tube that was for
sale in the catalog
and all of a sudden like he came
yeah this weird feeling came over me i
was like what the hell's happening and i
literally i think i passed out and i
woke up and there was a mess all over
myself
and i was like what was that
wow and you're a real man
oh thanks yeah i mean you know kids have
it easy these days like you said it's
whatever you could find back in the day
my dad had a subscription to this
magazine called fur fishing game
and it was a hunting magazine but they
that one of the issues had an ad for a
boat and it had two women in bikinis
like way in the background of the boat
and that was material for like a year we
were like little indiana joneses when we
went through puberty when i was a kid
because we used to break in
yeah going to find dirty magazines out
in the wild like we'd break into there
were rock queries in kansas and we knew
like all the guys that drove the heavy
equipment were kind of pervs and you
know they were they were unsavory
characters so we're like oh they had to
have hidden dirty magazines in those
road graders and all that equipment so
we'd break into the rock query at night
with flashlights and sure enough under
the the front end loader the seat
there'd be a pile of dirty magazines
it's you and all right like the fbi you
were an adventurer yeah tractors we'd
find them in tractors all the time i
guess yeah
i found a nudist magazine laying on the
in the bushes in roosevelt i knew there
was a corner where weird [ __ ] must have
gone on a house boulevard roosevelt long
island oh my god i used to buy used
dirty magazines at the pawn shop when i
lived in missouri and literally
the pages would be stuck together you
get like five of them for a dollar it
was a great deal
you